[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and maybe most importantly you are
certainly one of the leading countries
in terms of people most of them my
friends so it's an honor to be here
we'll be discussing various things
[Music]
[Music]
situation I think it's again about the
military and afraid such a big factor
and we're going to be discussing that
very much so it's an honor to be in
Ireland with my friend and he's doing a
great job as your Prime Minister I know
that six-point contention with respect
to press it as your border and I'm sure
it's going to work I know the focus
plays heavily on it
you crave the moody bad party table the
big thing that's going to be your border
and hopefully that's gonna work out I
think a lot of good minds thinking about
how to do it and it's going to be very
very good for but the border will work
out mr. president's comments for these
dangerous times and finally change was
pretty sure some breakfast
well I haven't heard those comments but
you know we have the cleanest air in the
world in the United States has gotten
better since I'm president we have this
water crystal plate and I was that one
crystal clean water in there so I
haven't heard his comments but we do
have we're setting records environmental
intelligence is concerned about as well
and further readings information from
the US side just to give us security
briefing on that we'll do our dirty
houses
is something not together very much with
not only Europe but with with Ireland
[Music]
going there and then as you know make it
a trip tomorrow to Normandy this was
just something that the likes of which
few people have seen anything like it
we're with the Queen and the royal
family or something very special many of
you were there I think almost all we
were there but it's been very well
covered and it was really beautiful and
tomorrow we go to Normandy and I'll be
leaving from dude back I'm staying here
overnight and I thought this would be
the best place I'd love to come to
Ireland and stay a Dewback and tomorrow
is going to really about great
relationships that we have with Yusei
and I really wanted to do this stop in
Ireland it was very important to me
because of the relationship I have with
the people and with your Prime Minister
citizen access to the e3 visa when you
give I didn't look at that we almost
made it last time it was one vote you
know that and we're located that I'm
sure there's something we're going to
discuss and I spoke to the one vote
who's a great senator by the way and he
really is is a great senator and
we think would that it be successful
he's a terrific person he's I mean do
any harm that I can tell you he was tell
me he loves Ireland actually so I think
will there be a good shape we had just
about a unanimous vote and they were
getting unanimous vote we just something
that they've been trying to do for a
long time so I want to do that for the
people violent but I want to do it for
the people in the United States that
what this look to happen that happened
to be organized well I think what's
going to happen is over the next period
that first they're gonna have to see
who's gonna be Prime Minister and I
think it's a very important decision
we'll see what happens over in the UK
because that's gonna be decision number
one who is going to be Prime Minister
and once that happens that person will
get it and try and make a deal and maybe
if they don't make a deal they do it a
different way but I know one thing
Ireland's are gonna be in great shape
I love is a special place that's going
to be a very good shape I don't think
the board is going to be a problem at
all
your son is that all the cameras well I
don't know the reports are correct
because one of the gentlemen who we deal
with is this is North Korea they're
talking about is somebody that we know
well he's a strong man he's a strong
person and they like to blame kim
jonghwan immediately but they said he
was killed and he wasn't he was at the
theater the other night so he wasn't
killed the other four people I know
nothing about but is it's an interesting
situation I think that they would like
to make a deal look we'd like to record
it with them we'll see how it goes it's
been going pretty well because there
hasn't been testing of anything major
and frankly there's been no nuclear
testing a long period of time when I
became president and before that as you
know it was all the time nuclear testing
ballistic missile pressing and now
there's nothing I think the Chairman Kim
would like to make a deal and I'd like
to make a deal with them I look forward
to seeing him in the appropriate time
and again one of the people they were
talking about that was supposedly
executed wasn't executed at all
well the corporation tax you mean the
fact that it's so low it is a very low
tax I have to agree you know we have our
tax very very low but they've done a
very good job and then your Prime
Minister's kept it there and these a lot
of companies here
[Music]
[Music]
they go high the companies are going to
move back into the United States that's
all it's very simple the people not
gonna have to worry about paying the tax
because the companies are going to move
back in to the United States it won't be
any tariffs as far as China is concerned
China wants to make a deal I have no
doubt about it and every signal is they
want to and at the right time probably
that will happen right now they're
paying many billions of dollars to the
United States we never got that before
from China and we haven't even started
it's relatively peanuts compared to the
numbers that we're talking about but I
think China wants to make a deal and
Mexico you know wants to make it you
know they have their entire delegation
right now going over to probably the
White House location but to negotiating
with our people and set it up by Mike
Pompeo and Bob Weiser Mike Pence is
involved so we have a great Mexico the
drugs that are coming into people that
are coming in unchecked
they're swapping up whether they're
coming up like that vidiians Mexico
could stop but they have to stop it
otherwise that we just won't be able to
do business it's a very simple thing and
I think they will stop but I think they
want to do something I think they want
to make a deal and they sent their top
people to try and then we'll see what
happens to that we should know something
okay
[Music]